daily mail also phenomenally bright teen
at melbourne private school so australia
claims she now identifies as cat
no joke as it's revealed why everyone is
being supportive
so when i talk to you about the slippery
slope i'm not making it up it happens
it's real here it is a teenage girl now
reportedly identifies as a cat
no one seems to have a protocol for
students identifying as animals but the
approach has been that if it doesn't
disrupt the school everyone is being
supportive
can you imagine what was just that this
was a source close to the family
if it doesn't disrupt in other words if
the kid goes into that school they're so
worried
about being criticized for not being
woke enough that if your kid went to
this school and said oh i'm a dog
started barking asking for treats as
long as it didn't disrupt the class
your kid would be treated as a dog
okay
in a statement the school said students
were presenting with a range of issues
from mental health anxiety or identity
issues
the herald son also reported there was a
boy who identified as a dog for a period
of time and has been treated by a
melbourne psychologist i'm surprised
that they sent that kid to the
psychologist to be frank
i really am because isn't that hateful
and bigoted if your kid says he's a dog
he's a dog you have to accept it
i'm really surprised they took that
route to be perfectly honest with you i
don't know how old this kid was
if it was a three-year-old that's just a
three-year-old being three if it was a
16 year old saying i'm a dog you may
have a problem on your hands maybe
maybe a little counseling is an order i
don't know i certainly wouldn't start
giving big pharma drugs that make him
more canine
i'm sure they exist
just so you know by the way furries
is in fact subculture of people tyler i
don't know if you knew this
who identify as animals often dressing
up in costumes as part of what they call
their
fursonas don't mock jed you say
tyler is not weighing in he's not
weighing in no i'm just caught by this
one comment it says uh
uh when a girl went to sit at a spare
desk another girl screamed at her and
said she was sitting on her tail
there's a slit in the child's uniform
where the tail apparently is
i mean but didn't you see this coming
when all the furry stuff started yes i
did what a six years ago eight years ago
yes i did i saw it coming and you see
you see
the slippery slope is getting slippery
and this is why i talk about this right
not to be funny although some of it is
funny yes you know what everyone looking
and acting like it's halloween
year-round can be entertaining to some
in the same
part of the world me tyler others
but if that this is why it's important
because if facts cease to matter
then where does it end
right if you can no longer say this is a
biological male this is a biological
woman if you can no longer identify a
man and as a woman because that's
somehow bigoted
where does it end with the furries tyler
has a picture on the screen that he
would like
can the audience see that photo now
tyler that you're pointing to yeah the
guys in the back will bring it up okay
guys in the back will bring up this
image um what does one say
what does one say and you know it i have
seen people in new york city
who dress as animals costumes maybe not
as i have not seen one quite as
interesting as this one i'm not even
sure what that's supposed to be is that
supposed to be a cat that's a furry it
looks like a they have whole conventions
a cat fox mix to me i'm not sure
well that's quite scary actually you
know if we were a kid and you went to a
costume party and it was just too much
the clown they used to say clowns were
scary that thing would send me running
right out of there five years old i'm
not gonna lie
but i've seen people in the city um
dress in costumes and behave as such we
had i used to live on 72nd street and
first avenue there was a health food
store
and there were two people that were
quite odd that would go in one was a guy
who thought he was a female but would go
in naked which meant the junk was out it
was exposed
and i would be in there like there would
be kids i'd be like this is ridiculous
never got thrown out naked public
displays of nudity never got thrown out
nothing sometimes would wear um those
little handkerchiefs that people wear
around their head as a little
winter dead of winter
dead of winter over the package
and there was another group of people i
saw a couple who dress in the furry
outfits
cat fox hard to tell what they are
really and they would behave as cats so
i'm talking walking on all fours going
down the aisle i'm not exa this is not
an exaggeration and the aisles in the
health food store were quite small so
occasionally i would brush a shoulder
with a furry
i mean these this is what happens when
you live in places like new york city it
just is and i remember talking to a
friend who lived in west texas at the
time and he was like you're making it up
i had to take video and i did one day
and he was like wow
i'll never move there
so you never know all i'm saying is when
facts and reality cease to exist the
slippery slope gets very slippery i
wouldn't be surprised if in 10 years we
all had to acknowledge you know people
as cats and dogs and surgeries weren't
being talked about big farmer be like
wow if we make cat ears and whiskers
there oh we could make a fortune maybe
they'll introduce some drugs to make
people more feline can i don't put it
past any of them i don't put it past any
of them to get involved in this way if
you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]